hi everybody and welcome back to another
edition of the gadget lab i'm michael
colori
i'm robbie hi
um coming up next week we are going to
be and by we i mean roberto and myself
and the entire gadget lab crew from
wired go team gadget lab we're going to
be at the consumer electronics show in
las vegas nevada otherwise yes at ces
yeah now how many times have you been i
don't know three four yeah 12 37
feels like 37 if you go once that's true
it's a giant show there's hundreds of
thousands of people there every
manufacturer of consumer electronics
except for microsoft and apple
will be there
uh everybody shows off a bunch of
products there's tvs stereos headphones
cars
anything that has a computer chip in it
a whole a whole hall just filled with
iphone cases why
so that's actually the big question for
the week why why do we go to ces well
for the most part c and first of all
it's it's scheduled at a weird time
everyone announces their their products
they want to sell for the holidays
before the holidays and ces after the
holidays yeah so that kind of kills a
lot of like big announcements um a lot
of the announcements are things that are
going to come out in six months three
months maybe not until the holidays
themselves for 2013. but
and this is a big bud
um there's always a chance while you're
going through and looking at all the
regular you know like i said iphone
cases tvs whatever you're gonna see like
this one product made by this like one
guy or girl at you know they built in
their basement in like minnesota or
taiwan and you're gonna be like this
this is awesome this is amazing this is
something that's a little bit different
it's not i android churn it's not you
know 17 versions of the same hd tv
there's always that chance that one
little thing
and that is that is really like one of
the reasons you go yeah i mean for me
it's basically it's an opportunity to
see all of
the manufacturers meet all of the
product people meet the ceos meet the
people who actually build the stuff all
the engineers
um in four days
yeah you meet like two three dozen
people and you never see them again
until next year when you all show up in
vegas again for this for the show so
it's like a mega meeting
because every time you have a meeting
with someone either they have to come to
your office or you have to go there and
if they're not in san francisco for us
then it's a webinar or it's a phone call
and those are all you know you never
quite get a real just but you get to sit
down and talk with all these
manufacturers about their products and
about future products and so that's
really helpful and a lot of times
they'll show you things that like robbie
said they're not coming out until
september uh and they'll show you things
they say are coming out in september and
then don't come out and then you see it
again at ces the next year and then you
all have a good laugh about uh-huh that
was supposed to be oh vaporware so
it's it seems kind of pointless on the
outside and you know you'll read a lot
of coverage on wired and elsewhere about
how ces has jumped the shark and how
it's just this big show and there's
really nothing
well yeah it is right that's what
everybody says about it so there's
nothing interesting in ceos this year
but there's always something interesting
you just have to look really hard and
it's mostly about the meetings about the
face-to-face meetings
and actually that's why a lot of the
manufacturers go
because they get a chance to meet with
like the guy who buys all the electronic
stuff from best buy or the woman who
buys everything that goes on the shelves
at target
and they get to show them their products
and try and sell their products to the
retail just distributors
uh so
it's it's sort of like a lot of uh
inside baseball kind of backdoor
skullduggery i don't know what's the
right word i'm looking for here a lot of
uh handshakes
behind the scenes
you see a lot of naval gazing there yes
and you will see naval gazing on wired
we guarantee that uh we're gonna the big
story every day about what's going on
we're gonna have photos every day
uh about all the cool little products
both the things that you were talking
about the little amazing things that you
see in the corner that nobody cares
about as well as the important stuff um
and what 4k yeah
the 4k inning we're calling it because
everybody's announcing a a ultra high
definition tv that's what it's called
uhd yeah 4k is cooler it sounds cooler
4000 pixels uh
a resolution which is four times the
resolution depth of a
standard hdtv that regular http you
bought like a
a year or two ago yes worthless burpless
spend 20 000 on a 4k tv why
throw it out with the christmas tree um
and then of course with 4k tvs there
come you know receivers that are capable
of passing 4k and uh surround sound
systems that have you know 4k upscaling
and downscaling in them and there's
going to be all kinds of crazy stuff in
that ecosystem also you know voice
control dictation software is getting
there we're going to see a lot of that
that's been getting there for 20 years
still still working on it um probably
see a lot more seven inch tablets
probably see a lot more windows eight
things that spin and snap and
break eventually yeah so you'll see a
lot of photos of that and a lot of
coverage of that um and we should also
mention we're doing a special tumbler
on it's going to be embedded in the
gadget it's going to be embedded in a
post on the gadget lab it's a live blog
24 7. it's a continuous the entire time
we are at ces we'll be updating this
post as a live blog so whatever we're
doing if we're getting a crazy demo if
we saw alicia keys
uh if we you know that'd be awesome
right fist bump the gizza in the men's
room
if what you've never done that
that sounds
awkward come on he's the genius
uh
we'll tell you about it basically it'll
be there um we'll have karaoke pictures
we promise also karaoke it's gonna be
really fun i think sometime around 11
p.m after 11 every night waiting to get
a little bit when the amount of of
exhaustion that comes from running
around like miles every day
is uh compounded with the free alcohol
that people tend to give us um that's i
think that's going to be the magic hour
eleven to one yeah right for a man who
from a man who doesn't drink i don't
drink though doesn't really drink all
that much i'll be taking a lot of
pictures of people who do drink so we do
have um
five pieces or ten pieces of unfinished
business right here uh before the
holidays we announced we were giving
away this pair of etra 5 point gloves
and these are gloves that are made in
the uk
from sheep
their wool but they also have special
fabric woven into the fingertips that
allow you to use them
with your touch screen devices so you do
not have to take your gloves off to
tweet or to insta or to facebook or to
snapchat or to poke or whatever it is
you do with your phone you filthy person
we asked our readers to send us photos
of their antiquated
telephony devices
and we have a winner and his twitter
handle if i'm pronouncing this correctly
is
it's uh
s-y-z-y-g-y
otherwise known as james hart good job
james james sent us a picture of him
showing off his nokia thx 41 phone uh
his one because first of all it has a
cool little antenna
and also his was the only one that
showed the device actually on and
operational he didn't have a signal but
it still turns on after all these years
he's ready for the apocalypse he is so
just in case um smartphones all like
fail they all give you cancer he'll
still have his thx 41 and he'll be cozy
with his five-point glove so we're
sending you a dm on twitter and these
will be in the mail to you shortly and
if you're interested in checking them
out you can check them out at etrips e t
e-t-r-e you'll see the url down there at
the bottom of the screen where you can
check out these gloves
if you'd like to own a pair since you
didn't win you loser
we'll see you
at ces we'll have videos
and updates on the site every single day
so check in and then we'll be back here
doing this show in the studio after it's
over to tell you about the cool stuff we
saw yeah
until then
foreign